I think people get the idea with
mindfulness that it's you've got to go
and sit under a tree somewhere and you
know in barley or you know and kind of
live that life and and it's very goal
orientated but actually you can live
mindfully in that way and that's often
the things that are taught in therapy
around um noticing and observing your
experience okay so I'm in this scenario
this feeling is coming over me I can
feel it you know in in this part of my
body or that part of my body and I
notice these thoughts are coming in and
I'm I'm going to allow that to be here
for a minute and I'm just going to allow
the next experience to wash over me and
I'm going to see how that goes so you're
not sort of grasping onto it for dear
life but you're also not pushing it away
you're kind of allowing it to be present
and when you don't either grasp it hard
or or push it
away it kind of takes its natural course
and it washes over you and it moves past
you